THANKS TO STEPHANIELAM FOR
K BACKNE'S LIFE.ANY MUSIC STARS
SIIBUTE TO TONY BENNETG
MICHAEL BUBLE WILLN US IN  BUT E
PL THE SITUATION
GRTO.
HOW ARU REMEMBERINTH
ICOUIEBENNET L
THOSE CLIPE.N INLIFE.
S GOOD TO BE WITH
THANKS FOR HAVING MEAD
BECAUS TONY
YE PROBABLY I THINK
WAS TEENAGER WN HE CAME
THROUG
T ET.
REMEMBSI HHAAN
UNBELIEVAB TALENT
BUT HE W S TO ME, ALWAYSIS ARMS
OPEN, OURAGINGWHEN I THINK ABOUI
BECAUSE HE WAS THE K GUY IO
STAGE H ME, BUT YOU
ALSOADO BE CAREFULECYOU KNT
THE MOE AND IT WASN'
GOING TO B.T OF
FELT THAT WAY, BUT H TON
BENNUNIQUE
AND ZZECAUSECH A UNIQUE D ICONIO
YOU KNOW, HE JUST HAD
INCREDIBLE ABITYNDUNS VOIC
WHEN YOU COUPLE THATS
MIAND HIS
INCREDIBLE AO --O
AN SOME OF
THE GR SONG  ONE OF THESE ONA
LIFE K
THERE WAS NOBODY WHO REALLY DID
WILL NEVER, ERYB ITHERE -- I CAN
DOES IT LIKE TONY BENNETT.
H,G
IN THE ROOM WITH HIM?
CK A
>> I'LL TELL YOU A QUICK STORY 2
PLAYA RE WERE A
OF SINE LINE-UP WAS I WAGOT TO S
VERY GOOD THING BECAUSE YOT NTY
THE MICRHO
LDE TO MY  B T I SAWHE WINGSCHI
HELD THE MIC ABOUT 2 FEET AWAY.
S N MY
SOE ND WENWATCHING THIS. SOUND N
OFFSTAGE.
IDHE WALKS OUT, SAYS GOOD EVENI,
LADIES A
D I'M KE I JUSNTED TO CRAWL INTO
YOU' NWIN.WHU LLY BENNETT.CAT.
THT TO TALK TOOU.CIATE YOU COMI
TH, AND MY HATS
OFF TO YOU A.N AMAZING CAREEROU
HAD, AND THANKS FOR SHARINTHE
SPECIAL RIES.
WEECIATE IT.LET'S BRING IN ANOT
MODERN DAY GRAMMY
AWARD WINNINTIBL UEAT TO SEE Y T
BENNETT ONEV TKE TO SIH N THE I.
AND, KA KID
THE ROEFE GREAAMERICONG
BOOKYOW
ME DER HIS WING, AND
LOVED JUST EVERY TIME I GOT A
TIMES BUO BE WITLK  HAND I REMEO
MR. BENNETT I HAVOLENYTU AND F
AND DEAN ATO ME,,  STEAL
IT'S RESEARC ETH Y STEAL FRO
D OL STORY SO MANY
ANNTINUEL FROM
THOSM.AT ACT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.AND THAT I STORY.R
UNTIL THE END AND JUSTAD THIS
POWERFUL VOICE THAT WA
UNMISTAKABLE
TO B
THAT CONNECTED W>> I THAT,E WASD
K KNEW IT.
THEY KNE
WH REA FASCINA,
THOUGH, IS NOW I
YEARTCHINGEI
IT'S A GREALWAYS
WAY BUSIE  AFI, AND HE
AND EV THOUGH TIMES CHANGE ANDD
GO YOUR AN'RLY CONNT KNOW E ANUO
AS COMING HERE OF MINEOUTSID OUL
DAY, I LOVED TONNNT.AND G G 24SS
SHE'S  ANDPA
THEIR WING, NOUR ONSIBILITY TO E
SUL WAYSE KEEP
THE LEY BUT
INE GREATE GIFT
AME GREAT AMERIC
P IT IN HI
AN HONO PRIVILE
TO BE ABLEDO THAT.
>> AND, REMARKABLE MUSAS E THAN.
TOUCHING JUST ABOUT EVERVER THET
WHAT SORCY
BEHIND DO YOIN THINK IT'R EN CHC
ANITBEOF OORTH AMERICA INCLUDINV
FOREVER.'LL BECOME POFOMENTS MAW
IN LOVE TO MTSYOU KNOW, WHENE A
IT'S A VERY E DAY FOR SO
MANY OF US.
YOU , D TO
DANNW REMARKABLE IT
WAS FOR ME ATH O
THAT HIKID HIM SO MD UNDERSTOOE
LE A PAR T
THIS
UDE MORE THAVANT T
I MEAN, IT IING IT IS.E MOVI I ,
AND JUST SORT OF S
MEANT FOO HAVE HIM IN
WORLD, HEYTHISS GUY', THAT REAL
IT DOES FO BET.
AT'S ALWAYS GOING TO STAY
R WE'VE HAD TIS OFORN OUR LIVES
UND
I K  WHAT'S GOING   SO SPECIAL .
NY IN R
LIVES.
>> HE SAID IT BEST
HEAMICAN ISTL IS.
>> HO QUESTION
WE'RE ALTHRILLED TO HAVE YOU
SO MUCH.R. AS WELL, THANKS
ANWHRIBUTE